[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 162 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm mark Mandel and I'm very excited to
be joined yet again by Gabby Ferrara how
are you doing today Gabby I am very good
thank you Mark for asking how are you
I'm doing okay
you're good to be joined by you yet
again on the podcast yeah I love being
here it's nice it's great so today we
are going to be talking to mohamed el
gush talking about voice ayah and voice
applications which I'm pretty excited by
yes then he will show us a different
ways how the approaching ml to solve
their problems that's gonna be fun
yeah it's really awesome and then
afterwards we have a question of the
week that I think you're gonna ask me
yeah so mark what if I'm working in the
terminal in called shell and I want to
move to another computer how can I
continue my work that's a great question
so we'll answer that later okay so why
don't we get stuck into that cool thing
of the week I think you had something
great up first so we announced this week
you will be able to query inside
bigquery without having a credit card
honest so that means that people like
students and other types of organization
can learn how to use V query without
having to provide financial information
and it provides up to 100 by the month
of querying capacity which is a lot for
a free tier so that's exciting for me
that's very very cool awesome and my
cool thing of the week we has a great
article talking about exploring
container security encrypting kubernetes
secrets with cloud KMS this is actually
really really cool so if you've used
kubernetes kubernetes has a thing called
secrets where you can store data in it
especially things like passwords and
whatnot but by default the kubernetes
secrets are stored in plain text which
if you want to put like really secret
stuff and there is not ideal but there
is a new thing in gke which is
application layer secret encryption that
is in beta right now that you can take
advantage of it's pretty straightforward
to set up all you really need to do is
specify the key that you want to use
inside cloud kms to manage your secrets
and pretty much you're good to go if you
have a look at the article it shows you
a little getting started guide as well
as links to some documentation to get
you going
cool also this week using that and
the Golden State Warriors announced they
are gonna be improving their fan
experience by using App Engine and
firebase together for maps so you have
the blog posts there explaining how it's
gonna be done and I have to confess mark
I did not kno what Golden State Warriors
work we admittedly we had to look it up
we had to go headline we're like oh it's
basketball in Oakland close to where I
live I feel like that's something I
should know yeah I'm sorry people that's
all right there's a really great article
by our VP of engineering melody McPhee
Seoul who we are huge fans of and you
can actually listen to her more in
episode number 158 from the podcast as
well
melody works very deeply in DevOps land
and she wrote an article talking about a
recent survey sponsored by Google cloud
by Harvard Business Review analytic
services talking about DevOps and
basically the road to DevOps and in the
blog post they outlined seven steps for
DevOps as well as a link to the survey
for more information but in there
there's piloting a small project being
an open-source player embedding security
within a software development process
apply DevOps best practices provide a
massive training establish and no blame
culture build a culture that supports
DevOps
etc etc so check out the blog post for
all the details as well as links to the
survey as well and to finish her list
The Telegraph in UK announced a
partnership with Google cloud to help
them to manage their media they're gonna
be using cool things like auto ml to
classify content so imagine all of those
contents that they have from way way
back
being able to classify out of ml and be
more searchable more easy to access now
that's very cool and I think I think
we're trying to get them on the podcast
too won't we
yes they're gonna be on the podcast and
they're gonna be able to talk more about
that I'll be interviewing them so stay
tuned well why don't we go have a chat
with our friend Mohammed over at Boise
yeah yeah let's go I am exceptionally
delighted to be joined by Mohammed LK
chief architect at voice yeah coming to
chat with us today on the podcast about
everything they do how you doing today
Muhammad good how are you doing pretty
well thanks so much for joining us today
and talking to us all about voice yeah
oh thanks for having me
so Mohammed what do you do is voice eeeh
and who are you tell us all right so my
name is Mohammed oh gosh I'm chief
architect and co-founder of Lycia I'm
responsible for design and other
architecture tasks here and I record I
do some other tasks founders to like
change evil light bulbs and all that so
almost everything you can imagine at
startup its restore II feel like that's
a thing yeah everywhere founders always
have to do that's awesome so tell us
about voice II air like at a high level
what is this company do yeah so as you
can imagine from the name or all about
voice and enterprise specifically so if
you think really about like how we use
voice in our day-to-day especially at
work they're like almost three big
categories one of them is actions that
you take so imagine for example if you
have like an assistant that collects our
google assistant and then you talk to
the assistant and execute the actions
for you like you know turn on the lights
and so on the big category for us is
that workflow integrations that you
actually want to automate a lot of
actions and enterprise you can imagine
you walk to a meeting and you can a lost
you don't know like what the agenda is
what is gonna happen after the meeting
is done and we want to automate the
process of distilling other outcomes of
the meeting in a very concise way and
converting those into actions so you can
say like our assistant is Eva what's the
stock price of Google today
create a task for me to follow up with
IT regarding security policies and this
becomes an actual action or tasks in
your task management system like turtle
or you know your system of choice and
then the other big categories
information so you are in a meeting and
you want to capture or query some
information from another system so like
for example like you can ask if okay Eva
so networks or social media I'm not
doing is focusing on the conversations
I'm focusing on the people there so
that's the biggest value add I think
when you're in a meeting you're very
focused you're present and you have
really high attention a queue so
attention code since I think so that's
the water was look for and you want to
be focused on the conversation and the
people around you and Evo will basically
take care of like taking notes one
you to assistant like this is an
important moment and this is an action I
want to be following up with that sounds
really cool you've also got integrations
with a bunch of different systems you
mentioned like action items and actually
doing things can you tell us what does
that actually look like in my day to day
you might like sending notifications to
by email or what are the cool things I
can do right so a lot of these systems
actually allow you to like send them
emails to create something in them you
can for example create a card and turtle
or create a task in JIRA or a ticket and
we plug-in into a lot of them so you can
actually go to our website and explore
with other systems we will plug into and
you can figure it easily with a single
like email address and if I will send
anything that you want to capture into
these systems and basically starting
that workflow kicking off that action
which is maybe creating a note or
creating a task and so on and so forth
if he met like you have your notepad and
your pin and you walk to a meeting you
can actually talk and you can tell Eva
that this is important and this is what
I wanted to capture instead of like
scribbling and you know maybe losing a
few minutes here and there of that
meeting you could have spent focusing
more on the people around you at the
conversation for sure awesome so yeah
you're the chief architect and this is
the GC podcast like when I get into the
technology side of things what
technologies do you use to make a
reality I'm guessing there's kind of two
parts to it I know there's like probably
the transcription but then there's also
like pulling out the highlights and the
action items and actually doing the
actions so what are the bits and pieces
that you're using here right so we're
really big on kubernetes it's something
that I have vidacup appreciation for
coming from a background where I
actually build something very similar
like you're soft it was really hard it
was really complex and we understand
like how life right now for startups and
companies that are growing is much
easier than it used to be like a decade
ago so you can actually just walk into
your terminal and type in a few commands
and voila you have a cluster running in
GCP which is amazing and you don't have
to worry I've heard a lot of things like
provisioning and scale and so on and so
forth so this is one of the biggest
items we have that we kind of don't
worry about so we let Google manage the
kubernetes installation for us and we
worry about the application and growing
the business
and basically the infrastructure is kind
of well taking you know care of and in
the gke world which is the google
kubernetes engine so our biggest like
focus now is just how to understand the
business and the growing the
integrations and growing like you know
the machine learning systems we have and
we don't worry about like auto scaling
or these things of course we understand
how Jiki works and we know how to tweak
it you know like our systems are very
kind of complex as well but it takes all
of complexity away for sure so compute
engine jakie stackdriver all of these
tools like you know also that storage
systems and whatnot are really great for
any startup to like go to GCP and like
start working on growing their business
and not worrying about managing you know
services like that so with all of this
tooling that you use sometimes you face
up challenges because you have a
learning curve you need to learn how to
stock driver I need to learn how to use
days how to use that how this affect the
development and the challenges that you
ended up facing for your product and
voice yeah that's a good question so
there are layers of abstractions that
might isolate you from the underlying
problems that a lot of distributed
systems face so back in the day when
you're building your own like set up
your own cluster you had to worry about
like where I'm gonna you know give my
machines so you know if I have to buy or
provision hardware I have to put it in a
data center I actually have to worry
about that rack space I have to worry
about networking ever to worry about
security physical security after about a
lot of things and then after all this
you still have to worry about the actual
systems that are running the databases
and file storage and backing up systems
redundancy high availability and on top
of all of this your application has to
be up and running and available and
performance and all these nice
characteristics so if you think about
the balance between doing all of the
above versus learning a framework or
learning something that's I think it
really thoroughly simpler like how to
work with kubernetes or how to work with
stackdriver
I think we're in a much much better
place today it of course can improve
meaning that there actually some
and some other companies whose entire
business model is basically simplifying
this even more but I think it's the
right balance for what I would call like
understanding the the complexity
underneath or basically peeling the
layers of the onion if you're working on
an operating system you need understand
a little bit of the foundations of this
operating system how it schedules tasks
how it manages files and so on and so
forth like in the world we live in you
have understand the data center
operating system which is in our case
kubernetes like how it schedules like
you know docker containers and what
happens when you know some conditions
are met and you know you might be in a
risk of losing your data or not so there
of course some constructs you have to
understand but for the most part I think
we're in a much much much better space
or place than before and that allows us
to move faster and focus on our own
application concerns versus like you
know learning way deeper things in the
stack and of course you know the the
thing I will emphasize in this is the
more you know the better you are like
knowledge is power and like if you
understand kubernetes very well and if
you understand how that stack driver
works you're gonna be able to like
perform faster and move faster yes I'd
love to hear more about like the flow of
information - in this system because I'm
guessing there's there's more to it than
just Krupa Nettie's right I'm guessing
there's like some audio coming in there
I'm processing maybe and then are you
running custom ml models you putting
like other tools in it like what's the
what's that flow of information how's
that how's that all getting processed
yeah it's a great question
so our basic input is audio right and
there's some metadata that are
associated with such audio recordings so
we join a meeting and we record what's
happening we also respond to commands
and that's technology in machine
learning known as the keyword spotting
so we don't this in a very like
real-time fashion that you want to
respond right away to the users commands
and execute them so there's a really
good like separation here between what
we can classify as the real-time versus
like Nearline versus offline processing
of audio and other metadata we would
consume and we depend heavily on like
binary stacks
the schedule all this workload for us so
the flow of the data is basically the
audio is being captured real-time and
we're responding to commands using
machine learning algorithms in legal
time and we do one pass on the
transcript and then we capture the audio
and store it and then we do another
multi passes on that and we produce the
transcript for the for the user at the
end so as you can see that you know the
the biggest thick focus for us is
actually how to be always available
capture the audio and not drop it and
also always be performant with really
low latency to respond to these commands
so that when you're having this
experience which is very fairly unique
you have a very powerful computer or
personal assistant on the phone with you
on the conference line so we're talking
now on this line and we can actually
invite Eva and either we'll be capturing
this and responding to my commands right
I'm telling Eva like highlight this or
this is an important note or take an
action and as an action item and so on
and so forth so all of these have to be
very performant and have very low
latency so we understand the
complexities of like how to route audio
and RTP or real-time protocol on top of
communities and we have like certain
requirements around like CPU utilization
and memory utilization for these systems
that are processing audio in real time
which is very important to understand
that you know the constraints of the
system when you're using one scheduler
versus the other and we're really happy
with the band's we have today in terms
of like how to like separate these like
workloads in different node pools and
the how to schedule them auto-scaling so
that we are not always like you know
over provisioning the machine so our
workload varies according to like you
know business hours in different
locations so we can actually kind of get
an idea of when we're gonna need more
machines versus we're gonna need fewer
machines and and so on and so forth for
each system so it's a very churning
problem but kubernetes is helping us
manage that very well yeah that's fun
what are you building your ml models in
oh so that's a great question about
machine learning in general and like the
philosophy or taking
and building systems so as a very fresh
or early startup when we started a
couple of years ago we had this like
list of principles about software
engineering in general and specifically
about like AI and machine learning in
which we set a set of guiding principles
for basically coming up with these
decision-making framework so when you
ask somebody in the team like hey what
are you gonna use to build this model
there should be a very easy kind of list
of criteria to like make a decision so
for example like as a company that's
centered around voice and the voice of
like our users is very important to us
to protect security is always top
priority for us so a lot of these
systems like in machine learning already
get about like you know like security
like we're serving them through
kubernetes so the training part of
machine learning happens of course like
a flying but if you're serving something
online we're protecting the data or
making sure that everything is secure
encrypted then we talk about like other
frameworks characteristics that meet the
other set of priorities for us or
guiding principles so you talk about bit
of iteration and speed of iteration or
velocity of iteration is extremely
important in machine learning machine
learning by definition or the way it's
it's done it's very iterative it's
extremely elusive meaning that you start
with some idea and you build some
hypotheses and then you say this will
work on paper and you actually go and
deploy it and the wild and you get some
feedback and you say like okay I'm gonna
have to improve this and now you collect
more data and you keep iterating on it
so there are a lot of frameworks today
like tensorflow and others make this
process extremely easy we have also some
flexibility around what framework you
use thanks to a new framework called
onyx that allows you to build models
using multiple frameworks and at the end
you can serve them using one of them or
a single like engine that you choose and
you can serve from that so we have some
flexibility and freedom that we allow
folks on the team to actually use
multiple frameworks including on the
cloud if they wish but at the end of the
day we try to standardize the serving
mechanism so that you always serve on
communities yes so with all this machine
learning that you do if
models how do you see you serving the
enterprise world where everyone has a
different demand everyone wants a piece
of you in a different way how do you see
serving enterprise and world yeah so
there's this concept of well-posed
machine learning problems in the sense
that these kind of problems when you're
trying to solve them you build up
something and you put it out there and
users have some experiences with them
and then they use the data that come
from the users or the results of their
output as feedback that they can learn
more and this is where we are actually
it's it's a virtuous data network effect
meaning that if you are using voice here
today and let's say you're in a meeting
and then if it transcribes something or
it's a task for you and there's a very
like jargony word that you use that if I
did not recognize you can go to our
interface you can fix it there and then
we will learn from that so that the next
time we would actually you know make our
best to like mitigate that or or fix it
for you and then the more users we have
from the same industry we can have a
more explicit effort to actually prepare
that the words that are pertaining to
that industry or that domain first
before you actually use the system or as
you can see the data effect the more you
use it the more it learns from you and
then becomes even more accurate so
that's really a good place to be at or
your problems will post ooh but what
happens if you have the same term being
used across different industries in
different ways yeah that's when actually
you have to collect some metadata about
hosts talking and it's more personalized
and then you can disambiguate between
the two how cool so they might sound the
same but they actually might be spelled
differently but because you know who's
talking first like you know I know
you're in your email address I know some
data about the speaker so it's more
personalized towards you so you
basically need the contextual
information right right and we get that
because you actually you know sign up
with us we know who you are and we kind
of let evil learn from your
indecent capacities basically so that's
how you learn in accents too because I
have problems of some assistance because
when I say some words they don't get it
what I'm saying and accent is really
hard you know yeah that's part of the
solution yeah nice that's pretty cool so
obviously you're doing a lot of voice
stuff is this just the beginning do you
plan on doing more where do you see the
voice interaction experience kind of
growing I would really love if I could
have demo our system because we are also
introducing some video elements
specifically when it's a presentation or
slides that your song inside the context
of meeting it's actually very
interesting to see the interaction
between the voice and the playback of
the slides and the highlights of the
meeting the minutes that we captured
it's very rich experience and we're also
looking for like something that we can
capture whether it's audio or video to
get more context about the meeting and
give it to you in a consumable format
that is easy to like you know integrate
with your workflow so today we actually
you know also will have some playback of
the slides or the video ad what is the
most interesting voice application you
created at voice see the most like
challenging and interesting thing you
did with that technology I have to think
a little bit about this there are a lot
of challenges in finding a start-up for
sketch yeah definitely when it deals
with like non-deterministic input like
speeds so you have a lot of machine
learning domains that are easier than
than speech or perceptual you know
knowledge acquisition so for example if
you're thinking of like recommendation
systems which is something I used to do
at my belief is life at LinkedIn I think
you have more leeway or you have more
freedom and Nick showing the user like
recommendations and so on unlike for
example the newsfeed but when you're
dealing with like human perceptual like
tasks like I've heard something and I
can make sure that you know I need to
make sure that this is the transcript
for it it's a bit more challenging I
want to say that for sure one of the
most challenging ones is keyword
spotting and you know responding to
commands it's almost a magical moment
when you walk to a meeting and then can
talk to the conference line and you
get stuff done that's for sure a very
like challenging process and to changing
problem because you need to understand
the intent of what the users saying you
need to understand where this
information should flow and you need to
convert that data into an actionable
outcome the combination of these
problems I think is the most challenging
and most interesting for sure fantastic
what's been the on the customer side
that what's been the most interesting
integration you've seen all definitely
integrations with task management
systems because a lot of people like to
keep track of what they're doing and
they think of meetings as a place where
they get work done and a place where
they can coordinate and discuss ideas
and then they come out with them some
like maybe handwritten notes or maybe
some cryptic notes they captured during
the meeting cuz you all really want to
be engaged and they just like type a few
words here and there but then now they
can just get other experience with like
very nicely
you know fished out lists of outcomes
that they just entered using our input
using their voice I think this is
actually where voice shines it's the
natural way of communicating with
computers so anybody is interested in
human-computer interaction or HCI
we can tell you that in the beginning we
had the terminal we had like just words
and a command line and very thick you
know dull way of interfacing because
that was the limitation of that era and
then we advanced a little bit to the
graphical user interface or GUI and also
because like you know we couldn't do
better than that if you maybe saw some
of the early systems that used voice or
other natural UI methods of input they
weren't that good back in the day so we
had to like you know resort to like the
mouse or the planner and then some icons
and whatnot but now with the richness of
machine learning techniques and deep
learning and all the advances we had in
the past I would say five to six years
it became possible to actually walk to a
room and have a $20 device that talks to
you and you can do things with it which
is in my opinion like it's just a
revolution of the UI and the way we
interact with computers overall does
that mean II should have been an email
you
probably are answering that question if
we see it right now right because all
the meetings you'll get all the stuff
keywords what is important you sent to
the integration systems for task
management so in the end you have
everything that you need just by having
your device or Eva help you I think I
think it's a very fair point
in the future I wouldn't exclude us from
doing something similar to tell you like
maybe you shouldn't attend this meeting
as a matter of fact we were working on a
lot of things that will help you make
the decision one of it is that we have
as humans intrinsic fear of missing out
or formal but you don't actually have to
sit there for an hour and listen to the
meeting if you can send Eva on your
behalf and if I come back reporting to
you like here are the important minutes
you can just you know spend one minute
or a couple minutes to listen to like
the important minutes or read them and
worked on this very amazing concept in
collaboration which is teams and
channels so let's say I manage a team
and we have a meeting with a client and
they want to share this meeting with me
so we can just create a channel and then
I have access to the channel that has
all this like clients meetings and then
I can coach them through it or I can
follow up with the the customers if I if
I needed to be in that meeting and I
couldn't make it for example or I'm
double booked or triple booked so for
most very important and we want to
specify that it by giving you like
here's what's really happening with this
excuse of meetings in a very Sesenta way
like here the highlights and I think you
know you can get a really good high
value from just reading those or
following up on those instead of
attending all of these meetings and I
wouldn't be surprised if we end up
answering the questions should this
meeting has be any minute said mm-hmm
all right or is it gonna be like don't
have meetings with John John tends to
waffle that sounds great
if people want to learn more about voice
EO like where should they go to learn
about this stuff so definitely
dub-dub-dub we see a dot-com
also on LinkedIn and Twitter Google
Voice eeeh and interact with us I would
love to hear your feedback and sign up
today it's free and get a trial for our
premium solution and I hope you enjoy it
cool and if anyone wants to learn about
any of the stuff you've talked about
today it sounds like you're working on
some really interesting problems do you
only resources that you recommend yes so
definitely feel free to reach out to us
we can get you a demo and if you want
each other personally I can also add my
contact information here and anybody on
the team we have an about page and
contact us page on voice datacom
fantastic before you run away is there
any other things that we haven't managed
to touch on that you want to make sure
that people know about I think as a
parting note this is a very exciting era
and I think folks like we've heard a lot
of things about AI taking over the world
and AI being this fourth revolution
after the industry revolution how it's
gonna change the shape and form of how
we do work I want to emphasize the way
where we're doing things and thinking
about AI more of an augmented
intelligence so it's not here to replace
your job some jobs you know over time
will evolve and change and some of them
are gonna disappear but I would send a
message to everybody to say like think
of AI is your friend and make sure that
you know more about like what's
happening because it's gonna affect how
we do work in the future its accelerated
definitely on an accelerated path right
now of course it's here to improve your
job not to take care of a different AI
thank you Mohamed awesome all right well
Mohamed thank you so much for hanging
out with us today and chatting to us all
about voice yeah thank you so much
thanks for having me thank you mohamed
al guys for helping us understand more
what the various CIA is doing and all
the insights that you gave on machine
learning on this episode yeah super cool
episode thank you so much for joining us
so mark the moment that you're waiting
for yeah question the week what if I'm
working a terminal called shell and I
want to move to another computer how can
I continue my work so that's a really
good question and I found this out the
other day I was really excited so if you
haven't use cloud shell it's kind of
Awesome it's basically an integrated
terminal that's built into cloud console
I also has a matching
and a whole bunch of other fun things so
it means that if you just want to like
get something done with g-cloud or maybe
cutesy TL or something like that and a
bunch of other tools that come with it
as well it's just a really handy way of
bringing up a terminal and getting
things done what's super cool about it
is not only do you get like persistent
dis storage for a certain amount of time
as well so you can leave stuff in there
and if you move from computer to
computer as long as you're accessing
that on a regular basis it stays there
which is really great what I didn't
realize and the implications of which is
it actually uses a piece of software
called T MUX in the background if you
haven't used that locally it's basically
a terminal session management it keeps
those those terminals alive and
persistent so what happens is say you're
working on one computer and you're like
that was cool and then you go to the
office and you're working on your
workstation for example and you're like
oh I wonder if there's still a running
process running or I want to check
what's going on you open up your
terminal and cloud shell will be like oh
hey I transferred your processes over
from like the old computer to this one
so you can still see what's coming on
and it's all the same so for example I
was doing a bunch of cleanup
I had a slew of app engine versions
lying around
and so I'd written a script to just
delete a whole bunch it was gonna take
about half an hour and I basically
started it at home and then got on a bus
and gone to work got to work and then
fired up cloud shell on my workstation
which wasn't my laptop and it was like I
wonder if it's finished yet and I popped
it up and I could see it was still
processing and I was in a completely
different browser in a completely
different computer and I was like that
is awesome mind blowing there's this
until joke that clock shows the best
product that we don't advertise so
there's only on the podcast pose with
the feature so take a look they're
absolutely fantastic
all right Gabby what are you doing what
have you been up to are you going
anywhere cool so I'm going to the Museum
of Natural History I never been there
before but I'll be giving a workshop on
MLA PI's and called functions for their
Brown Scholars Program which it is
forever cool high school girls so that's
gonna be nice because it's gonna be in
Python and they know more Python than I
do probably so okay so you'll teach each
other things yeah that sounds good that
sounds great fantastic and you Mark what
you're gonna be doing what am I gonna be
doing I think the the thing that's
coming up most in March game developers
conference we will be there all of
Google will be there in all its glory if
you're in
- cloud stuff though make sure to check
out all the sponsor sessions that we're
running on Wednesday we've basically
blocked out the day so if you wanna
learn about it Kahn is our up and match
our machine learning or all sorts of
other cool stuff that we're applying to
games definitely swing by and then
there's cloud next that is coming two
weeks after that I assume Gabby you will
be there as well at cloud next with me
yes
excellent excellent so I'll be
presenting there as well and I'm sure
you'll be there doing other fun stuff as
well I hope so
excellent and then way later down the
line in April I'll be at the East Coast
games conference as well so lots of fun
things lots of fun things and travel to
do yeah exactly
I probably won't be streaming this week
just because I need to get on a plane
and go back to Australia for a bit but
otherwise I'm sure I'll hop on there at
some point again soon okay I hope you
solve your problems there are always
more problems to solve their
never-ending list of problems okay right
okay thank you
all right Gabi thank you very much for
joining me this week again and thank you
everyone for listening and we'll see you
all next week
see you all later
[Music]
[Music]